I'm not huge into mean humor I'm just
not totally my style but there's plenty
of other stuff in there so there's a lot
to enjoy I [ __ ] love me and humor it
crack me up so much not it's very like
you know apparently the audience loves
me he dances dude it's not it's not
typically my thing so that's that I
guess I didn't feel it was fair to put
it on the list but like if there's
anything that if you're not in a mean
humor you know you might not laugh as
much as everybody else but there's still
a lot to laugh at you know definitely
it's a good time Jews Darren das there
any juices no it's something hey i'm
ryan right and this is my buddy Jerry
welcome two reasons to see where we give
you reasons to see and not to see the
heat so turn in your badge in your
weapon buddy
reason to see number one Melissa
McCarthy this is my favorite role of
hers I've ever seen actually you know I
like her more than this than bridesmaids
she's the real star of this movie you
know Sandra Bullock yes Top Billing more
famous the lead but Melissa McCarthy she
really steals the show in this movie
great [ __ ] job she's good at playing
fat people who are very obnoxious and
mean-spirited but have a heart on the
inside your take you just said she's
good at playing fat people yeah she's
good Alex she's good at playing fat food
cook you know there's always a little
bit of insecurity incidentals like you
know overweight always adds to the
character I'm not judging her for being
overweight I'm just saying it that's the
character does the burn healthiness is
adding to the character yeah you know I
really enjoyed her I don't know if I
quite enjoyed her more than than
bridesmaids but you know it's not about
comparing the two I think she does a
really good job here I'm always afraid
about Melissa McCarthy because I like
her and I'm afraid that holly was gonna
typecast surgery no not even that I'm
afraid holly was gonna put her on the
Zach gal I'm afraid it's gonna be Zach
Galifianakis syndrome where you see them
in this big ensemble piece and they're
the kind of weird funny one and then
they just kind of put them into all
these roles where the whole point is to
be an [ __ ] who says obnoxious things
yes they're type that does suck ass yeah
type cat but it's but it's like the
exact parallel to Zach Galifianakis and
I am happy that I still enjoy watching
her because I've gotten kind of sick of
Zack elf and I yeah yeah yeah that's
that it is a concern of mine that I'm
afraid I'm gonna get sick of Melissa
McCarthy one day like when I saw
identity thief I was like am I already
Cygnus well that was exactly exactly
i'll phone a cat syndrome to to the max
and that movie is annoying and in this
movie you know there are some dimensions
you know it's a hard roll not to make
annoying cuz this person's just foul
mouth just really mean-spirited she's
just a blabbermouth you know it says
it's in the movies annoyed by her so
it's hard to make a character it's
interesting to make a character very
likeable we're in the realm of the movie
no one likes that person you know she
does a good job making you like her
ultimately and sort of bringing you into
what's really going on beyond that tough
exterior so I think she does a good job
and what's really great she's hilarious
in it she's really really
my son my most crack out loud moments
came from her reason to see number two
Sandra Bullock I was really impressed
with what you did in this movie because
there's always an these buddy-cop types
of movies there's the straight character
and then there's the wild obnoxious loud
mouth kind you day like the blind side
yeah yeah yeah that's exactly what I was
yeah they're like you know you got
Sandra Bullock being all loud and crazy
and then you got you know you get a
quiet black guy quiet tall black dude
this joke oh weird but yeah no no I
think she doesn't really good job in
this moving to it it's nice to see her
back you know doing some comedy yeah
she's always had comedic chops yeah
actually she always has and she really
proves it here again then she still
hasn't plus like I think she's like 49
or something holy cow she is beautiful
looks like she's 32 or something she is
hot she looks good and she Melissa
McCarthy play off each other really well
and she's really good at playing that
more sort of straight tightwad character
yeah and it's what school is a lot of
times that straight type character is
usually not as interesting or is not
funny but no she's funny in the movie
there's some really laugh out loud
moments that she gives you the times on
the screen really does shine is not
their individual scenes with Melissa
McCarthy and sandra bullock are having
that excellent excellent back and forth
that makes me go i gladly watch a sequel
just because of these two in it and i
like i like the character go through
sandra bullock predictable sure but
still fun to watch reason to see number
three the directing and editing Oh
Phoebe called big you know anything I
think fig fig fig something like that
he's a director of bridesmaids he's
directed like a shitload of episodes of
Arrested Development ah that's all I
like you know so he's a great director I
think he has this incredible ability to
tell these comedies but the same time
have that level of heart have the drama
be just in tackling up but not to the
point where it takes away any comedic
elements you know what I mean and he
managed to direct a movie that had such
a fresh feel to a familiar formula it's
very obviously the he let his actors do
a lot of improv and that's why I like
that's why I said we have to commend the
editing because that's hard when you got
like hours of
impromptu look at and then you got to go
over funny if we put chopped it up like
this yeah you know so a really really
good job on just getting your actors to
work really well together great tone
throughout with the editing out I will
say this there are certain times where I
thought that you know like there were
some jokes that would play out and I'd
be like okay this this joke is getting
kind of long but by the end of it I was
like oh but but I get why you kept this
in there because it is funny Bunyan and
you know what's cool it's like this is
this is a movie that it's a buddy cop
movie but woman will love this movie too
I mean uh visiting you know it's like
it's like women'll of it dudes all of it
everyone all of it like it's it's not
you know it's not only pitched at one
you know set of people I think anybody
who's into comedy will dig it and it's
not bombarded with like I mean there's
some like violent mean humor but it's
not bombard of like cheap sex jokes
throughout to which I really appreciate
it i mean in this day and age with
comedies like [ __ ] like everything is
about like [ __ ] and penis and yeah i
mean it's it's all character jokes like
all those come yeah yeah exactly that's
impressive to me it's not exactly like a
wolf or a movie but is that kind of
humor words like you have these
ridiculous characters who say offline
outlandish thing kind of got the Apatow
banter going on yeah but if you're into
that kind of stuff I think anyone who
goes in is gonna have a good time you
know oh absolutely that's what decisions
not much action yeah I got a I got a
debate with you on this a little bit
because I I here buddy cop movie and the
way they advertised it I want action
when I hear and to me there's not much
action in it and when there is action is
not I'm not looking for something like
impressive but at least something a
little bit more fun and entertaining to
watch actually yeah I didn't think so I
really thought they could have used a
little bit more expanded more on the the
few action scenes that they did have I
guess I mean I was always caught up in
the thrill of like you know cuz it's
detective work and they're trying to
figure out who's behind this yeah with
the drug lords and stuff like that and
you know they have that sort of 70s cop
tone so I thought the amount of action
was appropriate you know I mean there's
there's this action in a sense with like
the idea of the detective work and
everything but you know I wanted to see
like some violent gunplay and [ __ ] like
that and fistfights go down and
everything but no I mean if you're going
mainly for the calm
yeah you're gonna get a total a kick out
of it for Ryan's consensus real laugh
out loud moments is the reason to see
the heat real laugh out loud moments is
the reason to see the heat yeah it's on
the trailer I was like this looks okay
watch the movie I was like this is great
[ __ ] love it Jerry's consensus funny
ladies kicking ass is the reason to see
the heat funny ladies kicking ass is the
reason to see the heat I think this
movie is a good time a lot of people are
gonna enjoy it it's got that edge ya
know for an r-rated you know summer
comedy it's a good time alright guys
thanks for checking out our review for
the heat why don't you go ahead go to
that comment box below and tell us what
is your favorite buddy cop movie what's
yours uh lethal weapon 2 and rush hour a
nice yeah nice and if you want to shake
him episodes reasons you want to check
out this link right here and click on it
and if you want to go ahead and follow
us on Facebook click the link right here
if you want to follow us on Twitter and
yes we will follow you back click the
link right here and last but not least
if you want to get updated every time a
new reviewer videos out subscribe
subscribe it's a hot button it's a high
it's a hot day it is actually we are
sweaty if ya could not tell I know it's
in black and white right now but he is
just this right side of his head is
sweat the whole front of your face is
shining is it yeah and your glasses my
glasses are fogging up do our thang yeah
I'm noticing that happening while I'm
talking to you it's hot in the RTS do
you know what you should do is you
shouldn't put this in black and white
you should tint it that sort of weird
copper blue tone they do in desert
scenes so it just looks like super hot
okay maybe look how does that look now
some crazy color correction yeah looks
good right oh hi yeah there we go right
right yeah Ryan Wright made the editing
better go back to black and white yeah I
like I like liking one Cheers
good she Vinci go no not gonna put that
you